welcome Xing rockstars I'm Erik Bosse
and diehard remains a go to action
classic the film that brought Bruce
Willis and Alan Rickman into our lives
and yes categorically a Christmas movie
I don't care what people say for Los
Angeles residents it perfectly
encapsulates every Christmas for us it's
80 degrees everything's on fire we go to
grossly extravagant company parties
filled with coke heads and we're all
barefoot fighting German terrorists it's
a weird town after breaking down home
alone last Christmas this year we are
ripping off our Christmas sweaters
flicking ourselves up in burrowing into
all the great details that you missed in
the real holiday classic that gets put
on the TV when your nieces and nephews
go to bed so you can finally stop
watching The Polar Express soulless eyes
let's get started the film opens with
NYPD detective John McClane arriving at
LAX to visit his wife Holly one thing
that diehard isn't given enough credit
for is how tightly it's scripted by
screenwriters Jeb Stewart and Steven
need to souza the genre of films that
inspired are known for being dumb
shoot-'em-up movies that your dad likes
but die hard screenplay is incredibly
clever first act is filled with
foreshadowing beginning with the
seemingly throwaway opening advice John
receives from a stranger after you get
where you're going take off your shoes
and your socks then you walk around on
the rug barefoot and make fists with
your toes
diehard would not be die hard without
McClane being barefoot the whole movie
his bare feet are what make him a badass
they are basically extensions of his
fists
director John McTiernan previously
directed predator an Arnold
Schwarzenegger what's considered for the
role of John McClane but bored with the
meat head action stars the 80s McTiernan
had the die-hard script rewritten to
make MacLean more of an average Joe
leading to Bruce Willis being cast to
other little things here John carries
this massive stuffed bear with a red
ribbon in the movie The Hunt for Red
October Alec Baldwin's Jack Ryan brings
home these same bear to his family and
MacLean checks out the flight attendant
it's pretty hilarious how in the first
half of this film
McClane unapologetically scopes out
every woman he passes because he's got a
Bachelor mentality because his marriage
is on the fritz
another woman jumps into her guys arms
at the airport this is actually a
Playboy Playmate of the Month July 1988
Terry Lynn das it's one of three
playmate cameos in movie which they did
to specifically bring out the whole
bachelor side of John McClane but then
we meet John's wife Holly
I think so atmospheric she goes by miss
Gennaro but then her daughter answers
the phone this way it's a subtle way of
introducing Holly's professional name
chage which goes on to play a crucial
role in the film's plot along with this
photo of her with the kids in John which
is the last one we see after a lot of
photos without him as if she's ready to
move this family along without him she
flips over the photo with him to
indicate her frustration with her
husband but ultimately this photo being
face down saves her and John when Hans
Gruber is in the office this husband and
wife conflict is the heart of the film
the screenwriter described how after a
fight with his wife he nearly died in a
car accident leaving him with the fear
of never being able to apologize to his
wife similarly McClane zark in this
movie is to learn to support his wife
apologize for being selfish and realized
that los angeles needs his super cop
skills as badly as New York does the
Nakatomi corporations in the limo to
pick up John driven by Argyle Nakatomi
Tower is the real-life Fox Plaza at
Century City in LA this is Christmas and
Hollis buy Run DMC and I see this line
as a declaration just because something
doesn't hit all the lame genre notes of
Christmastime
doesn't mean it can't be a Christmas
thing just like die hard as a film
checking in at the front desk McClane
realizes that Holly had changed her name
on his way in he also takes note of
these security cameras and security
guards refuses to drink the gross
holiday cocktail see even the party
McClane stay sober and that is what
helps him keep his cool when [ __ ] goes
down Holly's office door reads H M
Gennaro M likely for McClane but Gennaro
is spelled wrong maybe Holly didn't
bother getting it fixed because she's
still not sure if she's gonna keep her
name this way
or maybe it's a set dresser error they
walk in on Harry Ellis mid blow on
Holly's freaking desk yeah solid red
flag for what kind of [ __ ] this is or
you could just go by his ass kissing
laughs - mr. Takagi's joke didn't work
out so we got you a tape days
Pearl Harbor actually comes up again
later one of the vault passwords is a
cog II which was the name of the
Japanese aircraft carrier from which
kamikaze pilots departed in the attack
on Pearl Harbor
another key set up in this early scene
shown to watch later well go on Shawn
what are you embarrassed it's just a
small token of appreciation for all our
hard work it's a Rolex I'm sure I'll see
you later
Holly's Rolex does get seen later in the
final moment with Gruber MacLean stamps
off that watch sending Gruber plunging
to his death and speaking of the devil
let's talk about Hans Gruber one of the
best film villains of all time this was
the late great Alan Rickman's first film
role he had a background in the stage
the name Hans Gruber comes from our man
Flint James Coburn movie that tried to
cash in on the popularity of
double-oh-seven films Hans Gruber is a
villain in the book die hard was adapted
from Roderick thorpes nothing lasts
forever for bass Gruber on his
tyrannical father Gruber in his men
arrived in a truck marked Pacific
courier which the production designer
pointed out ironically translates to
messenger of peace in the third film die
hard with a vengeance and Atlantic
courier truck blows up a nod to McLane's
move from the west coast to the East
Coast
a Pacific courier plane also shows up in
the movies speed directed by Iain de
bont
the cinematographer of die hard so
technically the films are in a shared
universe an awesome shared universe fun
editing detail here they had to cut away
from Gruber and his men at the last
second to prevent showing his henchmen
running into the wall when they catch up
John and Holly play nice at first but
then a young couple bursts in this is
the second playmate cameo May 1982 Stark
and Malin but this interruption shakes
John and Holly out of their pleasantries
reminding them that they aren't a young
flirty couple anymore like these two are
they are older spouses in a messy messy
marriage so now they argue after John
makes this with his toes Gruber's men
begin shooting and as he sizes up the
situation
John this dog can't help but check out
another woman across the way Gruber
takes Takagi and he hums Beethoven's Ode
to Joy the music that plays throughout
this film
[Music]
it was suggested by McTiernan as the
musical theme of terrorists he
referenced that it had been used as the
theme of the ultra violence and
brainwashing sequence in Stanley
Kubrick's A Clockwork Orange
[Applause]
[Music]
Gruber execute stick a guy reportedly
Rickman wasn't comfortable with firearms
so the editor had to cut around him
flinching after John tries to alert help
with the fire alarm the guard Tony goes
up to investigate John kills him used
his body to taunt the others notice that
this bad news comes with the ringing of
the elevator bell throughout this film
this same elevator Bell dings again and
again the news it brings becoming
increasingly worse while shooting these
elevators scene cinematographer Yandy
bond got trapped in one of the elevators
which inspired him for the opening scene
of speed awesome shared universe up on
the top floor John runs into our third
playmate cameo centerfold pinup Jolene
Pamela Stein from the November 1987
issue later returns to a high fiber when
John radios 9-1-1 for the roof the
police dispatch computer shows phone
numbers these were the actual numbers
for the management of Fox Plaza dispatch
sends the other hero this story sergeant
al Powell played by Dominic veljohnson
Carl Winslow family matters avengers
endgame actually had a deleted scene
that cameo veljohnson as a firefighter
outside a burning skyscraper a nod to
his role in this movie john escapes the
elevator shaft into an air vent giving
us the iconic frame of this film
referenced in everything from the lego
movie to to stranger things season 3
powell checks in on the tower actually
while this is going on Argyle is
listening to Stevie Wonder's skeletons
in the limo down below
the terrorists posing the front desk guy
greets powell with a southern accent
evening officer what can I do for you
the fact that these Germans can fake
American accents for shadows the voice
that Gruber uses on John later John gets
Powell's attention by throwing a body
onto a squad car as Powell reverses
through our Geils back window you can
see the corpse flying off the hood over
the radio Gruber snap said John cowboy
sorry we had to bleep it it's YouTube
but on this subject
TV versions famously dubbed this famous
diehard catchphrase to make MacLean say
yippie Kay a melon farmer and the TV
version of die hard 2 it's to be clear
there are no melon farmers nor mr.
Falcons in many of these movies McClain
tells Powell this Arnold reference plus
the Rambo nod were shoutouts to the two
action stars first offered the role of
John McClane Schwarzenegger and Stallone
before the role was changed a suit an
average guy like Willis claimed verbally
sets him apart from these two men to
establish this as a unique action film
deputy chief Dwayne Robertson rides and
pulls rank and notice that he rides in
the backseat despite the front passenger
seat being open relishing his rank this
contrasts McClane in the opening scene
who rode in the front seat of the limo a
car you're supposed to sit in the back
of Robinson scoffs at Powell suggestion
that their inside man was a cop because
he could spot a fake ID no actually
before becoming an actor Bruce Willis
used to be a bartender
the terrorists light up the cops and
John stops em by nearly blowing up the
building with the stolen c4 robinson
complains to him that they're covered in
broken glass down there to which he
responds clinch words he will come to
regret later
cokehead Ellis tries to negotiate with
Gruber Hans Bobby I'm your knight the
terrorists bring him a can of coke and
not to him probably asking them for a
different kind of coke Ellis gets shot
FBI agents Johnson and Johnson
arrived their names were apparently a
dig at Dominic veljohnson name they
thought sounded goofy despite it being a
totally fine name
so as far as I'm concerned they can both
go to vel Johnson McClane and Gruber
meet face to face but Gruber uses an
American accent to trick him he
introduces himself as bill clay the
office directory behind him shows the
names
dacovia de Sousa in de bont nods to
Jackson ago via the film's production
designer co-writer Steven Yves de Souza
and cinematographer en devant de menthe
by the way shoots is seen in Dutch
angles with a tilted framing suggesting
the deception that both men are playing
on each other
Gruber with his fake accident McClane by
giving him an unloaded gun so Gruber in
Karl's shoot out the glass to force John
to run through it with his bare feet yes
apparently Willis wore rubber shoes
designed to look like his own feet which
is why his feet look a bit large as he
pulls out the broken glass he radios to
Powell this is a paraphrase of the
comedian WC Fields who proposed for his
own epitaph
here lies WC Fields I would rather be
living in Philadelphia though the phrase
isn't actually on his gravestone Bruce
Willis would go on to appear in a number
of the films of him night Shyamalan who
sets most of his stories in the Philly
area Powell reveals I shot a kid and the
FBI cuts the power which accidentally
opens the vault for the terrorists and
in this darkest moment McClane tells
Powell to apologize to his wife for him
he comes to terms with how he's been an
[ __ ] this confession is the key
change for John's character he goes from
selfishness to selflessness and right at
this moment
Gruber realizes who Holly is and now
John must fight to prove himself as a
husband from here forward John ignores
all other beautiful women he passes like
all the office hotties he passes on the
roof his focus is firmly on his wife
whom you'll notice he finally refers to
by the name she prefers
John defeats Karl with the chain after
smashing him into the wall notice the
upper right corner behind McLean the
actor playing Karl is watching offstage
but apparently left in the frame johnson
and johnson charge in on a helicopter
[Music]
worth noting that saigon was for the
americans a chaotic retreat not really a
badass victory similarly this helicopter
raid will end in disaster for both
johnson's finally john confronts Gruber
to save his wife he only has two bullets
left this moment right here is why die
hard being set on Christmas Eve is not
random it is crucial to the film's plot
it makes it definitively a Christmas
story John doesn't use just any tape to
stick that gun to his back because it's
Christmas Eve there is a gift wrapping
card in this office with Christmas brand
tape patterned with what's that sprigs
of Holly this is holly tape which john
uses to wrap a present for Hans and save
Holly perfect screen writing so Gruber
tries to drag Holly out the window with
him but John finally sees a Rolex later
and sins Gruber to his death paper rings
from the building the closest la can get
to a real white Christmas and in case we
missed it in the galley and earlier John
proves he learned his lesson in the way
he introduces his wife to Powell doesn't
need her to do that and who knows she
might still go by Holly Gennaro
professionally but in this moment upon
seeing her husband concede Holly
reaffirms her marriage vows and because
this is a great script and every
character gets an art Powell finally
draws his gun again and Powell's Karl QD
Martin's let it snow snow that will
sadly never be seen by the biggest snow
lover on the next ome payroll what is
your favorite unconditional holiday
movie to watch comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA by subscribing the rock
stars for breakdowns of everything you
love happy holidays unless you're
watching this next August
[Music]